let's talk about the central african
republic
the fighting there is so bad that more
than 200
000 people have fled their homes since
december most of them
across the river to the democratic
republic of congo
there's a tug of war between two men the
president who just got himself
re-elected in a messy vote
and a former president who's under un
sanctions and wants his old job back
an investigation was launched against
him but to this day his whereabouts
remain unknown so why did an election
stir things up
who's fighting who in the car and why
are the russians in there
the central african republic is a former
french colony that's basically the same
size as france but where france has
almost
70 million people the car has less than
5 million
and while it has a lot of natural
resources the average person lives on
less than two dollars a day
things were bad under colonial rule but
independence in the car
has also been a rough ride
the man meant to become the first
president died in a dodgy plane crash
in the 70s the cer had a brutal leader
who declared himself president for life
then emperor before the french got rid
of him
there have been coups two civil wars
and a handful of disappointing peace
deals it's a country
where corruption has been the nature of
governance
where the state has been absent from the
day-to-day
lives of ordinary people so 60 years
later the cer is
pretty much run by whoever has the most
guns
there are maybe 20 militias who control
two-thirds of the country
and do pretty much whatever they like
some of them started out with some kind
of cause
but many resorted to killing extortion
and fighting over resources
now the main rivalry is often laid out
as being between the celica which is
mostly made up of muslim groups
and the anti-balika who are mostly
christian fighters
but it's not as simple as muslims versus
christians
there are all kinds of shifting
alliances and other local disputes in
the mix
stabilizing the country is an enormous
challenge
especially outside the capital banki
they're vast
areas of country where nobody is in
control
okay to understand the fighting going on
now we have to get into the fight
between these two
president foster tuadera and former
president francois bozize
at one point they were in the same
government tuadera was bazi's prime
minister
so bazize took power in a coup in 2003
and he's been accused of having a hand
in all sorts of atrocities
which he denies fast forward 10 years
and buziz is overthrown by celica rebels
and he leaves the country what followed
were two years of conflict and chaos
the celica struggled to keep control
an alliance known as antiballica emerged
to fight the celica
it was made up of many christian
militias at the beginning the antibalaca
targeted
only the military base of the seleka
groups but then
distant turning to targeted attacks
against the muslim population
eventually france's military stepped in
and there was a peace deal between the
government
and some of the militias they called
elections and tuadera
ended up winning so in 2016 twyder is
the president
meanwhile baziz is in exile and he's
been accused of supporting anti-balka
rebels
which is why the un imposed sanctions on
him
now while tuadera was in office things
did calm down a bit
but militias still controlled large
parts of the country
and the peace deal ended up falling
apart so in 2019 the government signed a
new deal
with 14 armed groups the plan was to
integrate
some militia leaders into the government
and fighters into the army
things were looking up and the elections
last year were supposed to mark a new
start
and then bozize came back on the scene
[Music]
he returned to the car and wanted to run
for president
but the constitutional court banned him
saying he failed to meet the standards
of good morality
brazil himself had never relinquished
the desire to come back to power
it was no surprise that his return
kicked off a new cycle of violence
kicked off a new
start to political tensions
this time some celica and anti-balga
factions put their differences aside
and formed a new alliance called the
coalition of patriots for change
using guerrilla warfare tactics the
rebels have taken control of more than
two-thirds of the country
many say boziza is leading the rebels
though he denies that
bessey offered this coalition political
leadership
and money in unity as well these groups
have effectively declared that they will
not support
trojan now all of that happened before
the elections in december
so when it came time to vote many people
especially in rebel-controlled areas
either couldn't
or were too scared to
but in the end tuadera was re-elected
president
and even though opposition groups
accused him of fraud
the constitutional court ruled that he
won in the first round
you can imagine though how tuadera's
enemies reacted
the cpc that coalition of militias
stepped up their war
and people have been trying to escape
[Music]
[Applause]
they're running from murder rape and
kidnapping
more than half of its five million
people are in urgent need
of humanitarian assistance things are
now so much worse in a country where a
quarter of the population
was already displaced right now the
government is fighting a
huge group of heavily armed and
well-organized militias
so it's relying on outside help to turn
things around
300 french soldiers 11 000 u.n
peacekeeping troops
the rwandan armies in there russia too
they say to train the car army the
instruction
is happening in russian
so a whole lot of outsiders each with
their own interests
the people of the cer though have other
concerns
people want to be able to go back to
their businesses to the fields
not to be scared and not to have to
flee every month to the bush or to a
neighboring country
people reckon the best way forward is to
somehow revive that peace deal from 2019
to do that the president the former
president and all their allies need to
come together
but that won't be easy in a country with
a lot of players
and too many guns
al jazeera is always monitoring what's
happening in car so check our website
for the latest and youtube for reports
from our correspondents on the ground
i'll see you next week